seven seals seven rings Seven Brides for
the Scarlet King they gather round the
natal bed the foolish and the wise they
fear the child yet to be born whose
voice shall rend to the skies the
faithful what's the forest for the
coming of the king their lanterns bright
they wait at night for the new world he
shall bring the dragon waits in shadows
his breath will scorch the land the hero
in the castle draws his sword and makes
his stand the princess in the tower is
hidden far away but nothing under heaven
can keep the groom at bay they gather
round with leering smiles the solace and
the dead though her soul unwinds the
cruelest Minds will keep her in her bed
the Potter told his prentice to prepare
him seven jars six he made with grace
and skill the last his hands did Mar the
[ __ ] moon no more is howling gone its
morning black in their dreams its faces
prowling come to take them back
the king is in his courting clothes the
brides are in their beds the unborn
Prince's wait in sleep to raise their
eager heads the hens were in the
henhouse and seven eggs did lay til the
Fox crept in by dark of night and stole
the eggs away six were broken by their
bindings six no more shall sing comes
the seventh full unwinding and all the
bells will ring when the first had given
birth then all the birds did sing a
screaming cries did shake the skies as
she called out for her king by doctors
blade ii bade a life into the world on
time lee hyun near silent moon the
king's red flag unfurled his bride the
third remained unhurt her cries for help
ignored she stopped her life with a
surgeon's knife and gave it to our lord
the fourth prepares a dagger and places
it at her heart the perfect cure cannot
make pure what the King has set apart
the fifth once crown was bearing down
upon the Fox is set that then was sun
dead with a mighty thunder
apocalypse began on the sixth day the
walls gave way and the oceans turned to
ash her birth gave work as the earth
shook underneath the king's fell lash
the seventh bride will break the tides
the moon no more will shine there comes
a day not far away
she'll birth the death of time the
doctor never tells his God which one he
really seeks instead he hides himself
away and quietly he weeps their God's
own voice he makes the choice declaring
with their word
in fear and pain let her remain lest she
be like the third the doctor's gun ended
his run as he put it to his ear as she
was defiled the pitied child he gave it
to his fear her memory a fickle thing
the strongest shall endure when her
weeping starts to waver their drugs make
her mind pure
you